I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey, guys. Welcome to Office, ladies. Hi, friends. This week, we are doing something a little different. We are going to revisit an old episode. We're going to revisit the season two finale Casino Night episode. Yeah, guys, we're going to shake it up a little bit. We got so much love and feedback for this episode. And we really loved reading
我是詹娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎，女士们。大家好。欢迎收听办公室女郎。嗨，朋友们。这周我们要搞点不一样的。我们要重温一集旧剧。我们要重温第二季大结局《赌场之夜》那一集。是的，伙计们，我们要稍微换换风格。我们收到了关于这一集的超多喜爱和反馈。而且我们真的很喜欢阅读
your reactions. They cracked us up. Also, it was one of your favorite episodes that we had done. Remember, we had J.K. John Krasinski on to chat about those Jim and Pam scenes. And Jenna, Constance Gorham said, Casino Night was my favorite episode of The Office and of your podcast. I loved your conversations with John, the joy you felt when reminiscing about those backstage moments and the friendship you have was so sweet and definitely had me smiling while listening to it. Well, Constance, we agree. We agree with you. And that's why we want to go back and give this one a second look. We broke down a lot of stuff in this episode, but, Angie, we missed some stuff. What? We did. No. We did. People wrote in
大家的反应。它们让我们捧腹大笑。另外，这也是你们最喜欢的我们做过的剧集之一。还记得吗，我们请到了J.K.约翰·卡拉辛斯基来聊聊吉姆和帕姆的那些场景。詹娜，康斯坦斯·戈勒姆说，《赌场之夜》是我最喜欢的《办公室》单集，也是你播客中最喜欢的一集。我喜欢你和约翰的对话，喜欢你们回忆后台时刻时的喜悦，你们之间的友谊非常甜蜜，听的时候绝对让我面带微笑。好吧，康斯坦斯，我们同意。我们同意你的看法。这就是为什么我们要回过头来重新审视这一集。我们在这一集中剖析了很多内容，但是，安吉，我们漏掉了一些东西。什么？我们漏掉了。不。我们真的漏掉了。人们写信来
with more questions. We're going to answer those. And a little later, we are going to interview the director of Casino Night, Ken Quapas. Guys, Ken directed 13 episodes of The Office, including our pilot episode. I mean, he got us started. He also directed Diversity Day, Sexual Harassment, Booze Cruise, Gay Witch Hunt. He directed our 100th episode of The Office, Company Picnic, and our finale. We literally could not be more excited to talk with him today. I love this human. He is one of my favorite humans. I'm so excited for you guys to hear his awesome, sweet voice. He's just a delight. I can't wait. Go ahead. Go ahead. That's how he would say action. Yeah. Go ahead. He would also give me notes
提出了更多问题。我们要解答这些问题。稍后，我们将采访《赌场之夜》的导演肯·夸帕斯。伙计们，肯执导了13集《办公室》，包括我们的试播集。我的意思是，是他让我们起步的。他还执导了《多元化日》、《性骚扰》、《酒水巡游》、《同性恋女巫大搜捕》。他执导了我们《办公室》的第100集《公司野餐》和我们的结局。今天能和她交谈，我们真的无比兴奋。我爱这个人。他是我最喜欢的人之一。我很高兴你们能听到他那美妙、甜美的声音。他简直太棒了。我等不及了。开始吧。开始吧。这就是他喊“开始”的方式。是的。开始吧。他还会给我写纸条
like this. He would say, Jenna, you know what? In this next take, why don't you, you know what? Go ahead. Yes. He would start to give me a note and then not give me a note. I would be like, what kind of like ninja mind game is this? Yeah. We're going to ask him about it. Yeah. We're going to ask him about his ninja mind tricks. All right. We could talk about Ken a lot, but first, Jenna, we should probably get started with some things that we missed. Yeah. You guys, you said we missed things you wrote in. Catherine B wrote in to say in his talking head at four seconds, Michael says the Scranton Business Park is putting on Casino Night, not Dunder Mifflin. It does seem like Michael planned most of
像这样。他会说，詹娜，你知道吗？在下一个镜头里，为什么不……你知道吗？开始吧。是的。他刚要给我意见，然后又不说意见了。我会想，这到底是什么忍者心理战？是的。我们要问他这件事。是的。我们要问他关于他的忍者心理战的事。好了。我们可以聊很多关于肯的事，但首先，詹娜，我们大概应该从我们漏掉的一些事情开始。好吧。你们这些家伙，你们说我们漏掉了你们写信提到的东西。凯瑟琳·B写信说，在第4秒他的访谈中，迈克尔说斯克兰顿商业园在举办赌场之夜，而不是邓德·米夫林。看起来迈克尔策划了大部分
it and is the host, but just wanted to point it out since Angela was so worried about the budget. Wow. There it is. Four seconds, Angela. Four seconds in. We missed something, Jenna. One, two, three, four. Missed something. Exactly. I feel like this implies that all of the businesses may be threw in for the party or was it that Billy Merchant, the owner of the building through the party. It's Scranton Business Park. To me, that sounds like the businesses pulled their money and threw this Casino Night. That's what it sounds like to me. So that means like fans refrigeration participated, but then how did Michael get to be the host? Probably just because he's the loudest person at the meeting. Like, I got to do this. This
内容并且是主持人，但只是想指出来，因为安吉拉之前那么担心预算。哇。就是这样。第4秒，安吉拉。第4秒。我们漏掉了什么，詹娜。一、二、三、四。漏掉了东西。没错。我觉得这暗示了所有的企业可能都为这个派对出了钱，或者是不是大楼的所有者比利·麦钱特举办了这个派对。这是斯克兰顿商业园。在我听来，这就像是各个企业凑钱举办了这个赌场之夜。我听起来就是这样的。所以这意味着粉丝冷冻公司也参与了，但迈克尔是怎么成为主持人的？可能只是因为他是会议上声音最大的人。就像，我得做这个。这
is my deal. Because nobody else wanted to. I mean, I feel like everyone was probably relieved when, well, I don't know because they probably knew what it would mean to have Michael be the host. But no one else wanted the job maybe. So there you go. Well, we got another fan catch from Eliana Cornfield and Raymond Chen. They said, what day was the Casino Night? Because when Toby was telling Michael about why they shouldn't invite the Boy Scouts, he mentions that it's a school night. Do you mean invite or did you want to say, invite? I wanted to say, invite, like in John Voight. He invited them. He invited them. I've been watching normal people, all right? Collins and Mary Ann could solve their
是我的事。因为其他人都不想干。我的意思是，我觉得大家可能都松了一口气，嗯，我不知道，因为他们可能知道让迈克尔当主持人意味着什么。但也许没有其他人想要这份工作。所以就这样吧。好吧，我们从埃莉安娜·科恩菲尔德和雷蒙德·陈那里得到了另一个粉丝发现。他们说，赌场之夜是什么时候？因为当托比告诉迈克尔为什么不应该邀请童子军时，他提到那是上学前的一晚。你是说邀请，还是你想说，邀请？我想说的是，邀请，就像强·沃特那样。他邀请了他们。他邀请了他们。我一直在看《普通人》，好吗？柯林斯和玛丽安可以通过进行一次对话来解决他们
whole relationship by simply having one conversation. All right. That was like eight different mixes of accents. That's how I do it. I put them all together. I'll start again. We got another fan catch from Eliana Cornfield and Raymond Chen. What day was the Casino Night? Hmm. When Toby was telling Michael about why they shouldn't invite the Boy Scouts, he mentions that it's a school night. But when Jan leaves, Michael says, talk to you Monday, implying that it's a Friday night. Well, I think we all know what I have to say about this. Here we go. Why aren't they casual if it's Friday? If it's a Friday, why aren't we dressed casually? No, I know. By the way, a lot of people have written into me about this and said that in
整段关系。好。那就像是八种不同口音的混合。我就是这么做的。我把它们全混在一起。我重新开始。我们从埃莉安娜·科恩菲尔德和雷蒙德·陈那里得到了另一个粉丝发现。赌场之夜到底是什么时候？嗯。当托比告诉迈克尔为什么不应该邀请童子军时，他提到那是上学前的一晚。但当简离开时，迈克尔说，周一见，这暗示那是周五晚上。好吧，我想我们都知道我对这件事有什么要说的。我们开始吧。如果是周五，为什么他们不穿休闲装？如果是周五，我们为什么不穿休闲装呢？不，我知道。顺便说一句，很多人就此事写信给我，并说在
Michael Scott Paper Company, we're going to have an episode where it's explained that we are reinstating casual Friday as if for some reason it had been banned. I'm just saying we don't cover it. Okay. We introduce this idea of casual Friday and then we don't talk about it for four years. It's left me hanging. I'm sorry you were left hanging. Thank you. I feel for you and your other friends out there who are looking for those Fridays of casualness. Thank you. But the question is, what day was the Casino Night? It's unclear. I would think it would be a Friday because they're going to stay up late. They're going to gamble and drink and they don't want to go to work the next day. So I'm saying it's
《迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司》中，我们将会有一集解释我们将恢复休闲星期五，就好像出于某种原因它曾被禁止过一样。我只是说我们没有报道它。好吧。我们引入了休闲星期五这个概念，然后四年都没有谈论过它。这让我悬着一颗心。很抱歉让你悬心了。谢谢。我为你和外面的其他朋友感到难过，你们一直在寻找那些休闲的星期五。谢谢。但问题是，赌场之夜究竟是什么时候？这很不清楚。我想应该是一个星期五，因为他们要熬夜很晚。他们要赌博、喝酒，而且他们不想第二天去上班。所以我认为那是
a Friday. I agree with that. And I think maybe when Toby was saying that it was a school night, maybe he means they had school that day. But a school night means you have to wake up for school the next day. Maybe it's a Thursday. We don't know, Jenna. All right. Our next catch comes from Jeremy Cordell. If Dwight is wearing his grandfather's tux that he was buried in, wouldn't it be filled with bullet holes due to the shrewt tradition revealed last season of shooting their loved ones to ensure that they do not bury them alive? I think this also brings up another question. Jeremy, follow me. Follow me on this, Jeremy. After Dwight wore the tuxedo, did they then put it back on his grandfather
一个周五。我同意这一点。而且我觉得也许当托比说那是上学前的一晚时，他可能的意思是他们那天有学校。但上学前的一晚意味着你第二天得醒来去上学。也许那是周星期四。我们不知道，詹娜。好吧。我们的下一个发现来自杰里米·科德尔。如果德怀特穿的是他被埋葬时穿的祖父的燕尾服，由于上个季度的施鲁特家族传统——向所爱之人开枪以确保他们不会被活埋——难道这件衣服不应该布满弹孔吗？我觉得这也引出了另一个问题。杰里米，跟着我。听我分析，杰里米。德怀特穿过这件燕尾服后，他们又把它穿回到他祖父身上，
to then rebury him in a barrel? Or does he just get to keep the tuxedo? I mean, Dwight mentions his grandfather was reburied in season three, episode four, grief counseling. I think they removed the tuxedo, kept the tuxedo and put him in something else when they put him in the barrel. But he probably would have had the bullet holes in his suit. I think that's a very fine catch from Jeremy. Well done. So now, Angela, I have something I'd like to point out that I cannot believe we did not discuss last time. At 15 minutes, 35 seconds, we have an amazing shot of Mindy's hair extensions, full Mindy. She's wearing a flower in her hair. We've been literally talking about these extensions for episodes,
然后把他重新埋在木桶里吗？还是说他就可以直接留着这件燕尾服？我的意思是，德怀特在第三季第四集《悲伤辅导》中提到他的祖父被重新埋葬了。我想他们脱下了燕尾服，保留了燕尾服，并在把他放进木桶时给他穿了别的东西。但他的西装上可能还是会有弹孔。我认为这是杰里米的一个非常精妙的发现。干得好。那么现在，安吉拉，我有一件事想指出，我简直不敢相信我们上次没有讨论过。在15分35秒时，我们有一个非常棒的明迪接发特写，全套明迪。她的头发里戴着一朵花。我们实际上一直在讨论这些接发好几集了，
and we failed to mention them in Casino Night. Here they are, everyone. They are substantial extensions. Kelly has gone all out. Yeah. I can't believe we didn't mention those. Okay. Also, my friend, Jenna Fisher, people say I say lady too much, so I'm going to start calling you my friend. My friend. I would like you to call me Jenna Fisher. Oh, okay, my friend, Jenna Fisher. There we are. People also wrote in about Pam's hair, but you said, not a question, but I just have to say Pam's hair looks so amazing throughout this entire episode. And Melissa Lynn said, I bet there was another meeting about her hair. Jenna, you know there was a meeting about that hair. Come on, give it up. There was a huge meeting
而我们在《赌场之夜》中却没能提到它们。大家看，它们在这儿。它们是货真价实的接发。凯利真的是全力以赴了。是的。我真不敢相信我们没有提到那些。好的。还有，我的朋友，詹娜·菲舍尔，人们说我叫“女士”太多了，所以我开始叫你我的朋友。我的朋友。我希望你叫我詹娜·菲舍尔。哦，好吧，我的朋友，詹娜·菲舍尔。我们就是这样。人们还写信讨论帕姆的头发，但你说，不是问题，但我只是想说帕姆的头发在这整集里看起来都太棒了。梅丽莎·林说，我敢打赌关于她的头发还有另一场会议。詹娜，你知道关于那个发型确实开过会。得了吧，承认吧。确实开过一个巨大的会议
about that hair. And we tried, again, as we did, several different options for Pam's hair. Ultimately, we decided to go half up, half down, but instead of just having Pam let her hair naturally dry into that kind of frizzy curl, she would go back in with a curling iron and kind of soften her curls. We thought this was a good way for her to look like Pam, but like she'd given it a little effort, which seemed right on to me. So she would have had to blow dry her hair out straight, then get a curling iron and then put all those curls in, right? No, she let her hair dry naturally and then went in with a curling iron and just sort of softened the curl that was there. That's literally
关于那头发。我们尝试过，就像我们做过的那样，为帕姆的头发尝试了几个不同的选项。最终，我们决定选择半扎半披的发型，但不是让帕姆的头发自然风干成那种毛躁的卷发，而是用卷发棒重新处理，把卷度弄得柔和一点。我们认为这是让她看起来像帕姆的好方法，但又像是她稍微费了一点心思，这在我看来非常合适。所以她必须先把头发吹直，然后用卷发棒，再做出所有这些卷，对吧？不，她是让头发自然风干，然后用卷发棒稍微柔和了一下原有的卷度。字面意思就是
how we did that hairstyle. We did not blow it out first. Okay. I just wanted to know. I was curious about that. Yes. How many steps this was. Well, here's one thing I should mention. One of the discussions was that whatever Pam's hair looked like, it had to look like she did it herself. It couldn't look like someone else did it for her, right? And the truth is I could have never, ever achieved that little swirly. If you look at the back of my head, I've got this swirly thing there. It's a swirly bun thingy that holds up half the hair. Yes. Cause her Pam clip is not there. There's no Pam clip. It's a swirly thing with little pins. There's no, my arms couldn't bend in the way that would be necessary to
我们打造那个发型的方式。我们没有先把它吹直。好吧。我只是想知道。我对这个很好奇。是的。这有多少步骤。好吧，这里有一件事我应该提一下。其中一个讨论是，无论帕姆的头发看起来怎么样，它必须看起来像是她自己弄的。它不能看起来像是别人帮她弄的，对吧？事实是，我绝对、绝对无法弄出那个小卷儿。如果你看我的脑后，我有一个这样的小卷儿。那是一个像发卷儿一样的东西，撑起了半边头发。是的。因为她的帕姆夹不在那儿。没有帕姆夹。那是一个带有小发夹的卷儿。没有，我的胳膊根本无法以那种必要的方式弯曲，
achieve that. So a bit of a cheat. We went with that. Here's a little something for you guys listening. We always knew there was about to be a conversation about Pam's hair when Greg or one of the writers would come into hair and makeup because you never, ever saw them in hair and makeup. You'd see them on set, but you would rarely see them come into hair and makeup. So whenever they did, we were like, Oh, what's happening? Either Pam has a new hairstyle or Kate's getting her head shaved. What's going on? Well, here's what I thought was so funny was the number of meetings we had about my hair in this episode. And all the while, Mindy was three chairs down from me getting long, luscious extensions
所以有点像作弊。我们就用了那个。这里有一点小料送给正在收听的你们。我们总是知道当格雷格或某个编剧走进化妆间时，马上就要有一场关于帕姆头发的对话了，因为你绝对、绝对不会在化妆间看到他们。你会在片场看到他们，但你很少看到他们走进化妆间。所以每当他们进来时，我们就会想，哦，怎么了？要么帕姆换了新发型，要么凯特要把头剃了。怎么回事？好吧，我觉得最好笑的是我们为了这一集我的头发开了多少次会。与此同时，明迪就在我旁边三把椅子的地方戴着长而迷人的接发，
that no one questioned. No one questioned how and why Kelly suddenly has long hair. We curled my hair in a slightly new way and it was like seven meetings. We were very protective of Pam's hair. They really were. And good thing too, because, well, I mean, every once in a while we messed up with low pony, but we've already spoken about that. LP. We already covered LP. All right. I would like to talk about drink orders. Attract it. Attract it. And I want to talk about it. Here's the thing. At 20 minutes, three seconds, we see Jan and Carol. They are side by side at the bar, which is totally awkward. Okay. Guess what Carol ordered? What? Red wine. Okay. Keeping it simple. Yeah. Right? Yeah. Jan orders a
没有人质疑。没有人质疑凯利怎么突然有了长发，为什么。我们以一种稍微崭新的方式卷了我的头发，结果开了大约七次会。我们对帕姆的头发非常保护。确实如此。这也挺好，因为，我的意思是，偶尔我们在低马尾上搞砸了，但我们已经讨论过那个了。LP。我们已经聊过LP了。好吧。我想谈谈酒水订单。追踪它。追踪它。我想谈谈这个。事情是这样的。在20分钟3秒时，我们看到简和卡罗尔。她们并肩坐在酒吧里，这绝对很尴尬。好吧。猜猜卡罗尔点了什么？什么？红酒。好吧。保持简单。对吧？对。简点了一杯
cosmopolitan. You know, remember, cosmopolitan's were what I drank when I did my experiment with BJ Novak about getting drunk for the dundies. Remember I told that story? Is this because you'd watched like one episode of Sex and the City and you're like, oh, people order cosmopolitan. It's when they go to a bar. Lady, that's literally correct. Yes. I had done so little drinking that when I had to order a drink, I said cosmopolitan because it's what they drank on Sex and the City. Yes. Yes. 100%. I didn't know any, it was that or a screwdriver. I knew those two drinks. That's it. All right. So Ryan comes up and orders a seven and seven with eight Maricino cherries, sugar on the rim, blended if you
大都会鸡尾酒。你知道的，记住，当我跟B·J·诺瓦克一起为了邓迪奖而进行喝醉实验时，我喝的就是大都会鸡尾酒。记得我讲过那个故事吗？这是因为你看了一集《欲望都市》，然后就想，哦，人们会点大都会。去酒吧时就是这样。女士，这完全正确。是的。我以前几乎不喝酒，所以当我不得不点酒时，我说大都会，因为那是他们在《欲望都市》里喝的。是的。没错。100%。我不知道别的，要么是那个，要么是螺丝起子。我就知道这两款酒。就这样。好吧。然后瑞恩走过来点了一杯七加七，加八颗马拉斯奇诺樱桃，杯口沾糖，如果可以的话再打成冰沙
can. And then doesn't Jim say, oh, that's still going on. That's still going on, huh? He has perfect line. It's perfect. Well, at 14 minutes and 46 seconds, Michael goes up to Billy Merchant. And we did not talk about this scene and I have some info here. Okay. Michael says to Billy, your nurse is hot. To which Billy says, she's not my nurse. She's my girlfriend. And Michael says, your nurse became your girlfriend. Sweet. And Billy says, she was never my nurse. I met her at Chili's. All right. We had someone write in and I am so sorry, sir. I lost your name. Okay. If you hear this, you know who you are. There's only one person who wrote in and I cannot, could not find the email again. But they wrote
然后吉姆是不是说，哦，这还没完呢。还没完呢，哈？他有一句完美的台词。太完美了。好吧，在14分46秒时，迈克尔走向比利·麦钱特。我们没有讨论这场戏，我这里有一些信息。好吧。迈克尔对比利说，你的护士真辣。对此比利说，她不是我的护士。她是我女朋友。迈克尔说，你的护士成了你的女朋友。真甜蜜。比利说，她从来都不是我的护士。我在辣椒餐厅认识她的。好吧。有人写信给我们，非常抱歉，先生。我把你的名字弄丢了。好吧。如果你听到这个，你知道你是谁。只有一个写信的人，而我找不到，再也找不到那封邮件了。但他们写信
in to say is Billy Merchant's girlfriend, the same woman who played the hostess Megan from Chili's and the client. Remember in the client, we loved how Michael kept remembering that the hostess name was Megan. He was like, Megan, Megan. Okay. Okay. No. It is not Megan from Chili's from the client, but it is the same actress who played the waitress at Chili's in Dundee's. What? And her name is Amanda Warren. This actress Amanda Warren. She was a background performer in the Dundee's episode. She played a waitress and we hired the same actress to play Billy Merchant's girlfriend in Casino Night. That's some good continuity. Good continuity. Come on, some good continuity. And by the way, thank you, Kentopedia, for
来问，比利·麦钱特的女朋友，是不是扮演辣椒餐厅的女招待梅根以及那个客户的同一个女人？还记得在《客户》那一集里，我们很喜欢迈克尔一直记得女招待的名字叫梅根吗？他一直在说，梅根，梅根。好吧。好吧。不是。她不是《客户》里辣椒餐厅的那个梅根，但她确实是在《邓迪奖》里扮演辣椒餐厅女服务员的同一个演员。什么？她的名字叫阿曼达·沃伦。这位演员阿曼达·沃伦。她是《邓迪奖》那一集里的背景演员。她扮演了一名女服务员，我们雇了同一个演员在《赌场之夜》里扮演比利·麦钱特的女朋友。这真是不错的连续性。不错的连续性。得了吧，真是不错的连续性。顺便说一句，谢谢你，肯百科，
doing that deep dive on our casting file to get me the answer to that question. No, Kentopedia. Well at 15 minutes, 51 seconds, Michael sits down at the poker table to play No Limit Texas Hold'em. Michael goes all in against Toby. Toby calls. Michael gets really mad. Toby shows a pair of jacks and then Michael folds his cards and storms away from the table. We have a fan question from K. Gooth as a poker player. Did it bother Jenna that when Toby calls Michael's all in, Michael just leaves even though he could still win? Yes. Yes, K. Gooth. Yes, it bothered me a lot. Also in the script, it said that Michael turns over his cards revealing a 9 and a 10, which means he could have won by landing a straight,
在我们的选角档案中做了深入的研究，帮我找到了那个问题的答案。不，是肯百科。好吧，在15分51秒时，迈克尔坐到扑克桌前玩无限德州扑克。迈克尔对托比全押了。托比跟注。迈克尔气坏了。托比亮出一对J，然后迈克尔盖上牌，气冲冲地离开牌桌。我们有一个来自K·古斯的粉丝提问：作为一名扑克玩家，当托比跟注迈克尔的全押时，迈克尔明明还可以赢却直接离开，这让詹娜感到困扰吗？是的。是的，K·古斯。是的，这很困扰我。另外在剧本里，上面写着迈克尔翻开了他的牌，露出了一张9和一张10，这意味着他如果拿到顺子本可以赢，
right? If he gets a straight, that's going to beat Toby's two jacks. Here's the thing. You never walk away from the table. In the scene, Michael doesn't reveal his cards. He just folds his cards. So I guess we're left to presume that they were really awful, but you never know what you're going to get on the flop on the turn and the river. You never walk away from your hand. Thank you, K. Gooth. It did bother me. K. Gooth, none of that made sense to me. None of what Jenna said made sense to me, but I'll tell you what I'm going to take away from it. I am not walking away from the table. There you go. Thank you. Angela, at 20 minutes, 23 seconds, I don't think we discussed Creed's stealing of the poker
对吧？如果他拿到顺子，就能打败托比的两张J。事情是这样的。你永远不要离开牌桌。在这场戏里，迈克尔没有亮出他的牌。他只是盖上了牌。所以我想我们只能推测它们真的很糟糕，但你永远不知道在翻牌、转牌和河牌时会发生什么。你永远不要离开你的手牌。谢谢你，K·古斯。这确实困扰了我。K·古斯，詹娜说的那些我一点也没听懂。詹娜说的没有一句是我能理解的，但我会告诉你我要从中吸取什么教训。我不会离开牌桌的。就是这样。谢谢。安吉拉，在20分23秒时，我觉得我们没有讨论克里夫偷扑克牌的事情。
chips, which becomes a bit of a runner. Yeah, it's a total runner throughout the episode. And as far as I can tell, Angela Martin is the only person that really clocks it, right? Yeah, but then you don't say anything. I don't say anything. You think that's interesting? Angela, do you think that your character, because your character clocks a lot of things. Do you keep a little file? Oh, do you think maybe you file that away somewhere for use later? I think that's one of the things Dwight and I have in common. He's tracking all kinds of stuff. And so am I. And so when the two of us think that we're going to have power together, we're like, oh, we own these people. Oh, you guys definitely have some secret files.
薯片，这就成了一个有点像贯穿始终的梗。没错，这几乎成了整集的一个持续不断的梗。据我所知，安吉拉·马丁是唯一一个真正注意到这一点的人，对吧？是的，但随后你什么都没说。我什么也没说。你觉得这有意思吗？安吉拉，你觉得你的角色——因为你的角色注意到了很多事情。你是不是有个小档案袋？哦，你觉得你会不会把这些东西归档存起来以后用？我觉得这是我和德 Dwight 的共同点之一。他在追踪各种各样的事。我也是。所以当我和他觉得我们俩要一起掌握权力时，我们就会想，哦，这些人都在我们的掌控之中。哦，你们俩绝对有一些绝密档案。
For sure. Well, lady, I think we should bring Ken on because now I have questions for him. Same. Here's what we're going to do. We'll take a break, and then we will be back with the director of Casino Night and many other episodes. Ken Cuepas. Go ahead. And go ahead to break. Ken Cuepas. Hello. Ken Cuepas is here, everybody. We are so thrilled to have you. I am so happy to be here. Ken, you and I share a hometown. We do. And I have a very distinct memory about one of our first meetings. So I went to an all boys high school in St. Louis, St. Louis University High School. All boys. And the only girls I met in high school came from two sister schools, Ursuline Academy and Narrings. And those were the girls who
肯定的。好吧，女士们，我想我们应该把肯请上来，因为现在我有很多问题要问他。我也是。我们接下来这么办：我们休息一下，然后我们将和《赌场之夜》以及许多其他剧集的导演肯·奎帕斯一起回来。肯·奎帕斯。请进。请进休息时间。肯·奎帕斯。你好。肯·奎帕斯来啦，各位。我们非常高兴你能来。我非常高兴能来。肯，你和我老家是同一个地方。没错。而且我对我们的初次见面之一有着非常深刻的记忆。我曾在圣路易斯的一所全男子高中上学，圣路易斯大学高中。全是男校。我在高中见过的仅有的女生来自两所姊妹学校，乌尔苏拉学院和纳林斯。而这些女生就是
like were actors in our plays. Yes. So anyways, when you and I auditioned, I remember having this moment where I thought, wow, this woman has such a weird Catholic girl vibe going on here. She reminds me of like the girls I knew from Narrings High School. And that's where you went. That's where I went to school. Yes. And the only boys I knew came from St. Louis University High School to be in our place. No, it was the weirdest, most random thing. And but obviously there's a there's an important St. Louis contingent on the show, obviously. There's a huge one. It's you guys and Ellie and Phyllis. Am I missing anyone else? Rusty Momwood, our first AD. Rusty. Oh my gosh. Yeah. I really wasn't aware of
我们话剧里的演员。没错。所以无论如何，当我们去试镜时，我记得我有这样一种感觉：哇，这个女人身上有一种好奇怪的天主教女孩气息。她让我想起了我在纳林斯高中认识的女孩。而那就是你上学的地方。那就是我上学的地方。没错。而我认识的仅有的男生都来自圣路易斯大学高中，他们来参加我们的话剧。不，这真的是最奇怪、最随机的事情了。不过显然，剧组里有一个非常重要的圣路易斯派系，显而易见。有一个非常庞大的群体。就是你们、埃莉还有菲利斯。我还漏掉其他人了吗？拉斯蒂·蒙伍德，我们的第一副导演。拉斯蒂。哦天哪。是的。我其实并不知道
how many people were from St. Louis until the World Series. That one season when everyone was watching, remember, it was like, I'm going to get it wrong. But anyway, I just remember you guys were really intense about baseball. And I was like, why? You guys were all from St. Louis, right? It was a bad World Series that year for the Cardinals. Oh, yeah, we all are so quiet. I thought I was bringing up a really great memory. You guys are like silent. I'm like, what's happening? Okay, sorry. Okay. Okay. Well, Ken, we always like to ask our guests how they came to be a part of the office. And you were our first director. You directed our pilot. We'd love to hear how that happened. Well, I, you know, I did
有多少人来自圣路易斯，直到世界大赛那阵子。就是每个人都在看的那个赛季，等等，我可能会说错。不管怎样，我只记得你们对棒球真的超级狂热。当时我就想，为什么？你们都是圣路易斯人，对吧？红雀队那一年的世界大赛表现挺糟糕的。哦，对，我们大家都好安静。我还以为我挑起了一个特别美好的回忆呢。你们却像哑巴一样不说话。我都不知道发生什么了。好吧，抱歉。好吧。好吧。那么，肯，我们总是喜欢问我们的嘉宾他们是如何加入《办公室》的。而你是我们的第一位导演。你执导了我们的试播集。我们很想听听那是怎么发生的。嗯，我，你知道的，在
not know Greg before the show. I, I met with him. I had an interview with him. I was actually very nervous to meet him because I knew his work. I really admired him. I also was nervous because like, so many people said, this is a terrible idea to remake this show with the office. And so I went into this job interview with these, all these different feelings, including like, you know, what if I get this job? This is this, this is an impossible task, making this beloved show. And I don't remember much of the meeting except for one thing. And that is Greg asked me when I thought of the British show, I said, I really loved it, but that I was completely confused about the layout of the paper company in the British show.
剧集开拍前我并不认识格雷格。我，我跟他见过面。我跟他面谈过。其实见他的时候我很紧张，因为我知道他的作品。我非常钦佩他。我也很紧张，因为有太多人说，用《办公室》这个剧来拍美版是个糟糕透顶的主意。所以，我带着各种复杂的心情去参加了这场工作面试，其中包括：万一我得到了这份工作呢？这简直是一项不可能完成的任务，要翻拍这部备受喜爱的剧集。除了有一件事之外，我对那次会议的记忆已经很模糊了。那就是，格雷格问我对英版有什么看法，我说我真的很喜欢，但我对英版办公大楼的布局完全一头雾水。
I just found it totally, I couldn't figure out where, you know, where people sat or anything like that. And I remember even in the meeting thinking, this is a really bad move on my part, you know, like you, in theory, you know, you hire a director because they have, I don't know, visual sense. And here I was basically saying, I'm like, spatially challenged. And Greg, to my delight, he goes, Oh yeah, I'm totally confused about that too. And then we, we were sitting, I don't know where the meeting took place, but we were sitting on a sofa. And then we kind of scrunched down next to the coffee table and got pieces of paper and pens and started like drawing like we were a couple of kids, we were like drawing what we
我只觉得太乱了，我根本搞不清大家都在哪里办公之类的。我甚至记得在开会的时候心里还在想：我这一招可真是臭棋啊，你知道的，理论上来说，你雇用一个导演是因为他们有，怎么说呢，视觉感。而我在这里基本上是在说，我的空间感有问题。而格雷格，令我欣喜的是，他说：“哦，对，我也完全被那个搞糊涂了。”然后我们，我们坐着，我记不清会议是在哪里开的了，但我们坐在沙发上。接着我们有点挪到了茶几旁，拿出了纸和笔，开始画画，就像两个小孩一样，我们开始画我们
imagined the original paper company layout was like. So that was I think the turning point of the meeting. Oh my gosh, I love that story. I guess that, you know, it's, it's a little bit the lesson of, you know, sometimes it's okay just to admit what you don't know, I guess. It really speaks to Greg too, because I could see Greg getting a bunch of paper and saying, let's draw it. Let's figure it out. Oh, that's exactly what it was. The two of us just like little kids drawing for a while. So when you got the job then, how did you approach building the Dunder Mifflin world? Did you scout real offices? Cause you know, our first location was that real office in Culver City. How did you choose your space? Well, the space, as I recall,
想象中的原版办公大楼的布局。所以那可以说是会议的转折点吧。哦天哪，我喜欢这个故事。我想，这也许算是一个教训吧，有时候，承认自己不知道的东西其实也没什么大不了的。这也真的很符合格雷格的性格，因为我能想象到格雷格会拿出一堆纸说：“我们把它画出来。我们把它琢磨明白。”哦，情况完全就是这样。我们俩就像两个小孩子一样画了一会儿。那么当你得到这份工作时，你是如何着手建立邓德米夫林这个世界的？你有去物色现实中的办公室吗？因为你知道，我们的第一个拍摄地点是卡尔弗城的那间真正的办公室。你是怎么挑选空间的？嗯，那个空间，据我回忆，
the office suite that we shot in was just this kind of shuttered office, you know, there was nothing going on. It was basically a big empty rectangle. There was nothing in it really. And I remember a lot of questions that Greg and I, you know, batted back and forth, including should there be dividers between the desks? Should there be cubicles? And, you know, or sure if there are dividers, should they be low enough that you could, people could still kind of see each other over them? And, and we decided, you know, happily to have no dividers except accounting and accounting, which is also a very bizarre divider because you can still staring at each other. Well, you know, I have my theory. I have my theory that Angela Martin
我们拍摄的那个办公室套房只是一间废弃的办公室，你知道的，里面什么都没有。它基本上就是一个巨大的空矩形。里面真的什么也没有。我记得格雷格和我反复探讨过很多问题，包括办公桌之间要不要隔板？要不要设隔间？还有，你知道的，或者如果有隔板的话，它们应该矮到人们依然能透过隔板看到彼此吗？然后，我们决定，很高兴地决定除了会计部门之外不设任何隔板，而会计部门的那个隔板也非常奇葩，因为你依然可以互相对视。嗯，你知道，我有一种理论。我有一种理论，认为是安吉拉·马丁
requested that because she needed a buffer between her and Kevin because he's, you know, he's a little smelly. I remember even when we decided it would be glass, it was like, well, what's the point of having that divider? But I think it was just sort of, we wanted some sense of that somebody was in a cubicle, the kind of thing. And, but I do remember spending a lot of time thinking about the relationship between Pam's chair and Jim's chair. That actually was something that I played around a bunch with different ways that I mean, Pam's, you know, your, your reception area was always where it was. But it was a question of where would Jim sit? And I, you know, and it seems now like, how could it not be what it was? But I love the idea that
要求那样做的，因为她需要在她和凯文之间加一个缓冲，因为他，你知道的，身上有点体味。我甚至还记得，当我们决定用玻璃时，心想：那设那个隔板还有什么意义？但我想那只是某种程度上，我们想要有一种某人在隔间里的感觉，诸如此类。而且，我确实记得花了很多时间思考帕姆的椅子和吉姆的椅子之间的关系。这其实是我花了很多心思通过各种方式来处理的一件事，我的意思是，帕姆的，你知道的，你的前台区域一直都在原来的那个位置。但问题是吉姆该坐在哪里？我，你知道的，现在看起来，怎么可能会不是后来的那个安排呢？但我很喜欢这个主意，就是
you were, you always look at Jim and Jim has to turn to look at you. It's like the simplest thing, but I thought that somehow the way your desks related would help tell the Pam Jim story. And so I love, nothing makes me happier than some of the shots we did where like John's in profile in the foreground and you're in the background, Jenna, like gazing at him. And he either is unaware that you're looking at him or he's completely pretending to be unaware. And he knows very well that you're looking at him. So I just feel like that was actually something that was like a key moment in setting, setting up the Dunder Mifflin world. I love that. Sure. And that would have been totally different if, if Jim sat where Dwight
你总是看着吉姆，而吉姆不得不转过身来看你。这虽然是最简单不过的事了，但我认为你们桌子之间的相对位置在某种程度上有助于讲述帕姆和吉姆的故事。所以我很喜欢，没有什么比我们拍的一些镜头更让我高兴的了，比如约翰在前景中露出侧影，而你就在背景中，珍娜，深情地凝视着他。而他要么是没有意识到你在看他，要么就是在假装完全没有意识到。其实他心里清楚得很，你在看着他。所以我只是觉得，那实际上是构建邓德米夫林世界时的一个关键时刻。我太喜欢了。当然。如果吉姆坐在德怀特
sits. Yeah, they'd be staring at each other all the time. Oh, I love that. And the other thing, you know, I was thinking about our, you know, morning at 30 minute exercise where, you know, that actually that exercise was inspired by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant. They said that when they shot the British show that every morning or occasionally they would just stop and do what they called general views. And they were basically different establishing shots. And so when we did it, I didn't really think about it at the time, but I really feel like it sort of set the tone for the day in that once we kind of segwayed into a scripted scene after, you know, a half hour of shooting shots of, I don't know, you know, like Angela, you, you know,
坐的地方，那情况就会完全不同了。对，他们就会一直大眼瞪小眼了。哦，我很喜欢这个。还有一件事，你知道的，我在想我们的，你知道的，每天30分钟的练习，你知道，其实那个练习是受到瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特的启发。他们说他们在拍英版的时候，每天早上或者偶尔他们会停下来做他们所谓的全景镜头。这些基本上就是不同的定场镜头。所以当我们做这个练习时，当时我并没有多想，但我真的觉得它在某种程度上为这一天定下了基调，因为一旦我们在拍摄了半小时诸如，我不知道，你知道的，比如安吉拉，你，你知道的——
doodling a picture of a cat or something. Like when we segwayed into a scripted scene, everyone kind of maintained that sense of just being like under observation, you know, nobody was doing a scene. It was that's, you know, everyone was still sort of being, I was still just eavesdropping on these characters as opposed to, oh, let's do a scene. Yeah. You know, the other thing that was great, I mean, none of the phones on the set worked, obviously, they were all dummy phones, but it kind of gave some of the cast members who didn't have dialogue in the pilot, like Phyllis didn't have, doesn't have a line of dialogue in the pilot. But when we were doing our morning exercise, she was like on this fake phone, improvising a sales call. And so I remember
涂鸦一只猫之类的镜头之后，过渡到有剧本的场景时，每个人都保留那种仿佛正处于被观察之中的状态，你知道的，没有人是在演戏。那是，你知道的，每个人都依然在某种程度上处于，我依然在偷听这些角色的状态，而不是“哦，我们来演一场戏吧”。对。你知道，另一件很棒的事是，片场所有的电话显然都不能用，它们全都是道具假电话，但它确实给了一些在试播集中没有台词的演员，比如菲利斯在试播集中没有一句台词。但当我们在做早晨的练习时，她就像是在拿着这个假电话，即兴进行销售电话的通话。所以我还记得
actually filming her. And so it was kind of a great way to, for all of the cast members to start to find their voice, even if they didn't have words in the script. Well, Ken, one of the things I remember as well, just was watching you and our camera operator watching you and Randall sort of like scope out the look of the scene. And we would rehearse for the crew and you guys would watch and your eyes dart back and forth, back and forth from who's talking and you're looking around. And I would find myself if I didn't have lines in the scene, I would only watch you. I would watch you watching the scene, figuring out where you wanted the camera to be and how you wanted to tell the story. Well, I can't speak for other directors. And obviously,
当时真的在拍摄她。所以这对于所有演员来说，是一个开始寻找自己声音的绝佳方式，哪怕他们在剧本里没有台词。嗯，肯，我记得的另一件事，就是看你和我们的摄像师看着你和兰德尔大致观察场景的视觉效果。我们会为剧组进行排练，而你们俩会看着，你们的眼神来回闪烁，看着谁在说话，然后环顾四周。我会发现，如果我在那个场景里没有台词，我就会只看着你。我会看着你注视着场景，琢磨着你想把摄像机放在哪里，以及你想如何讲述这个故事。嗯，我不能代表其他导演。而且显然，
the show, there's so many great directors who worked on the show. But I, for me, it was always critical to stand next to the camera, not to be off watching at a monitor. And part of what excited me was because I was standing next to the camera, I could see everyone who wasn't on camera. And so, for instance, like Jennifer, we were looking at you, but Angela, I caught something that you were doing out corner of my eye. If we did another take, I might say, you know, find Angela at some point. So it just gave me a sense of where we might look. I mean, Greg put it really well when he was on the podcast, when he talked about Booze Cruise. And he talked about, I mean, among Greg's many talents is the way he sort of empowers
这部剧，有那么多优秀的导演参与过。但是对我来说，站在摄像机旁边至关重要，而不是远远地坐在监视器后面看。让我兴奋的部分原因在于，因为我就站在摄像机旁边，我能看到所有没有入镜的人。所以，举个例子，比如珍妮弗，我们在看着你，但安吉拉，我用眼角余光捕捉到了你在做的一些动作。如果我们再拍一条，我可能会说，等下找个机会拍拍安吉拉。所以这只是让我有了一种我们可以把镜头转向何处的直觉。我的意思是，格雷格在播客里谈到《酒水游轮》时，把这一点表达得非常好。他谈到了——在格雷格的诸多才能中，其中之一就是他赋予了
the camera operator. And he, you know, sort of encouraging the operator to kind of get curious about what's going on, to look for things, to find things, to kind of get interested. And I think that's such a, I mean, it's such a fantastic way to approach the camera operating. But for me, at the beginning, it was mostly I just needed to figure out what else could the camera fine take to take. Anyways, that's a long, a long, long way of answering the question. No, I loved that. The other thing that I loved was the idea that the camera would be, quote, in the wrong place. So we did, we didn't do this a lot as time went on. But at the beginning, there were a few times where, for instance, like, Jennifer, I was on you, but Angela,
摄像师某种权力。而且他，你知道的，某种程度上鼓励摄像师对正在发生的事情产生好奇，去寻找事物，去发现事物，去对之产生兴趣。我认为这真的是一种，我的意思是，这是一种非常棒的摄像方式。但对我来说，在开始的时候，主要是我只需要弄清楚摄像机还能捕捉到什么别的画面。不管怎样，这是回答那个问题的一种漫长、漫长的方式。不，我太喜欢了。我喜欢的另一件事是，摄像机有时会处于，引号中的“错误位置”。所以我们没有随着时间推移经常这样做。但在开始的时候，有几次，比方说，珍妮弗，我的镜头正对着你，但安吉拉，
you had a line. And then we whip over, but we'd get to you too late, Angela. So we arrived just for like a dead bit of dead air. So we'd get there and couldn't get the line. So I occasionally, it was great to kind of choreograph some of those missteps a little bit. There's a lot of great times where it just feels like deliberately the camera is not quite ready for what's about to happen. I was looking at diversity day again, because I wanted to see, you know, Pam falling asleep on Jim's shoulder, which may be like my favorite scene that I directed in the whole series. I love that scene so much. But what's nice about it is, and I'm sure it's Randall, that when, Jenna, when you lean over onto John's shoulder, we're not quite framed for you. And
你有一句台词。然后我们猛地把镜头摇过去，但我们到达你那里时太晚了，安吉拉。所以我们到达时只拍到了一段静默的空白。所以我们到了却错过了台词。所以我偶尔觉得，把其中一些失误稍微编排一下是很棒的。有很多绝妙的时刻，感觉摄像机好像是故意没有完全准备好应对即将发生的事情。我又看了一遍《多元化日》，因为我想看看，你知道的，帕姆在吉姆肩膀上睡着的那场戏，这可能是我在整个系列中执导的最喜欢的场景了。我太喜欢那个场景了。但它美妙的地方在于——而且我敢肯定是兰德尔拍的——珍娜，当你靠在约翰的肩膀上时，我们的构图其实还没有完全对准你。所以
so suddenly the camera sort of like quickly zooms into a tighter shot. But at the beginning, it's kind of just a kind of a loose frame with the two of you and maybe a couple other people. Yeah. I wanted to ask you, Ken, about marks on the ground. So when I came out to LA and I had my theater degree, I took a bunch of on camera acting classes. And the big thing I learned was how to hit your mark. And a mark is a piece of tape on the ground that the actor must walk to and stand on because the camera has meticulously measured the distance from the mark to the camera so that everybody's in focus. And like hitting your mark was a thing that I was constantly nervous about as an actor. And I remember coming in on the pilot and asking, where is my mark?
突然之间，摄像机就像是快速变焦拉成了一个更紧凑的镜头。但在开始时，它只是一种相对宽松的构图，画面里有你们两个，可能还有另外几个人。是的。我想问你，肯，关于地上的标记。当我来到洛杉矶时，我拿到了戏剧学位，我上了很多镜头前的表演课。我学到的最重要的一点就是如何找到你的标记。标记是地上的一段胶带，演员必须走到并站在上面，因为摄像机已经精确地测量了从标记到摄像机的距离，好让每个人都在焦距之内。而且，像找到你的标记这件事，作为一名演员，我一直感到很紧张。我记得刚进组拍试播集时问：“我的标记在哪里？”
Because I'm now a professional actress on a television show and I must hit my mark. It's the one thing I learned from my classes. Ask where your mark is. So I'm like, where is my mark? And you said no marks. The actors shall have no marks. And so I was like, no marks. What did I spend that $350 on? But wait, I have a question though. Did it feel weird to not know where you were supposed to stand at times? It was such a relief because it freed me up. I had started every scene as an actor on camera, not thinking about where did I just come from? What's my emotional life? What am I doing in this scene? I started every scene with, am I standing on my mark? Like that's what was going through my head was, did I stand on it properly? I think I'm off.
因为我现在是电视剧里的职业演员了，我必须找到我的标记。这是我从课上学到的唯一一件事。问你的标记在哪里。所以我当时就问：“我的标记在哪里？”而你说没有标记。演员不应该有任何标记。所以我当时想：没有标记？那我花那350美元学费是为了什么？等等，我有个问题。有时不知道自己该站在哪里，这种感觉会不会很怪？这简直是一种解脱，因为它解放了我。作为一名镜头前的演员，我以前开始每一个场景时，想的都不是：我刚才从哪儿来？我的情感生活是怎样的？我在这场戏里在做什么？我开始每一个场景时都在想：我是不是正踩在我的标记上？这就是我脑子里转悠的想法，我刚才有没有站好？我觉得我站偏了。
Should I look down? I looked down. Did it look obvious? So it was so wonderful that I wasn't worried about where I was standing. You would just say, just land in this general area. You know, walk over to Jim's desk somewhere between here and here. Wherever you land, we'll find you. An important part of that is that we had a lighting plan that for the most part meant that you could land anywhere and you would be equally lit. That's the key. I mean, I would say there's nothing against marks because if we're doing a scene where we have some complicated lighting going on, you do occasionally need to actually hit the right spot. Yeah, you can't be too far off or there will be no light on you.
我是不是该往下看？我往下看了。这看起来很明显吗？所以不用担心自己站在哪里真是太棒了。你只会说：“就站在这个大致区域里。”你知道的，走到吉姆的桌子旁，在这两个地方之间随便哪个位置。不管你落脚在哪里，我们都会找到你。其中很重要的一部分是，我们有一套灯光方案，在大多数情况下，这意味着无论你落在哪个位置，你都能受到同等的照明。这才是关键。我的意思是，我得说这并不是针对标记有什么意见，因为如果我们正在拍一场涉及复杂灯光的戏，你偶尔确实需要准确走到那个特定的位置。对，你不能偏离太多，否则你身上就没光了。
But I think that that was part of it. But the other part of it was just the idea that generally that we were never staging things for the camera. Well, we were. We were always staging things for the camera, but we were creating the illusion that we were simply sort of observing what was going on as opposed to choreographing something for the lens. You know, I just love the idea that we had to follow you. We were the documentary team. We came in each day. We don't know what you guys are going to do and we're just gathering footage. Well, speaking of documentary crew, Ken, one more thing that you established. I'm not sure if we've shared this with people about the talking heads that you can sat in the place of the documentarian. So when we started
但我想这是其中一部分。而另一部分则纯粹是因为，总的来说，我们从来不会为了摄像机来走位。好吧，其实我们是。我们总是为了摄像机来走位，但我们创造了一种错觉，即我们只是在单纯地观察正在发生的事情，而不是为镜头编排某种走位。你知道，我就是喜欢这种我们需要跟着你们走的感觉。我们是纪录片摄制组。我们每天来到这里，我们不知道你们要做什么，我们只是在收集素材。嗯，说到纪录片摄制组，肯，你确立的还有一件事。我不确定我们有没有跟观众分享过，关于那种你可以坐在纪录片拍摄者位置上的单人访谈镜头。所以当我们开始时，
and then with every director that followed you, you sat next to the camera and asked us a question before we delivered our talking head. And early on, especially Ken, you would start our talking heads by asking us general questions about our life, about our weekend, and you would sort of gently lead us to a prompt that would then get us to deliver our scripted talking head. And that was kind of an exercise that we did in the beginning. But I think a lot of times people don't know this. You deliver things like that to like a piece of tape or to a tennis ball that you're just meant to look at so that your eye is in the right place. But you were like, no, I want you to deliver this to me, a human being and look at me and have a conversation
而且在你之后的每一位导演都是如此，你都坐在摄像机旁边，在我们进行单人访谈前向我们提问。尤其是早期的时候，肯，你会通过问我们关于生活、关于周末的常规问题来开启我们的单人访谈，然后你会温和地引导我们说出提示词，进而让我们说出剧本里的单人访谈台词。这可以说是我们在初期时做的一种练习。但我想很多时候人们并不知道这一点。你们通常是对着一段胶带或者一个网球说话，你只需要看着它，好让你的视线落在正确的位置。但你却说：“不，我要你对着我这个活生生的人说，看着我，和我进行对话。”
with me. I thought that was such a brilliant decision and it helped us so much. It helped so much. And I think you guys listening out there, when we sat in the chair, we were immediately in character and we didn't know what Ken was going to ask us. And it really for me helped me discover so much about Angela Martin. It was sort of like this acting exercise, Ken. Well, one of the things I thought about was the fact that a lot of the talking heads were very short. I mean, some of the most wonderful talking heads are like just one line. So it felt like, I mean, for me, the challenge is like, how do you make one line feel like it's part of a conversation? In theory, if I'm the documentary filmmaker, I did ask you a bunch of questions and then
跟我来。我觉得这是一个非常棒的决定，它对我们的帮助太大了。帮助太大了。我想你们这些在听节目的听众，当我们坐在椅子上时，我们马上就进入了角色，而且我们不知道肯会问我们什么。对我来说，这确实帮助我发现了关于安吉拉·马丁的很多东西。这有点像是一种表演练习，肯。嗯，我考虑过的一个事情是，很多单采镜头都非常短。我是说，一些最精彩的单采镜头就像只有一句台词。所以感觉就像，对我来说，挑战在于，你怎么能让一句台词感觉像是对话的一部分呢？按理说，如果我是纪录片制作人，我确实问了你一堆问题，然后
in the editing room, pulled this one line out. So it was just a question of, and by the way, it was actually hard for me because I had to come up with different questions before teeing up the scripted line. And I wasn't even sure what I was going to ask. But it just mainly was a way to keep it conversational. But I thought it was also important that as characters, that everyone started to develop a relationship with the quote, documentary team. But I just felt like the documentary team is like important off-camera characters in the show. Yeah. I used to love being surprised by your questions. Like I have a memory one time you said to me, what do you think about Kevin? Those are the type of questions you'd ask. And I was like,
在剪辑室里，挑出了这句台词。所以这只是一个问题，顺便说一句，这对我来说其实很难，因为在抛出剧本台词之前，我必须想出不同的问题。而且我甚至不确定我要问什么。但这主要只是一种保持对话感的方式。但我认为同样重要的是，作为角色，每个人都开始与所谓的“纪录片团队”建立关系。但我觉得纪录片团队就像是剧中的重要幕后角色。是的。我以前非常喜欢被你的问题吓到。就像我记忆中有一次你对我说，你觉得凯文怎么样？这就是你会问的那种问题。我当时就想，
I try not to think about Kevin. You want to ask some of the questions of the people wrote in? Yes, let's ask some fan questions here. Ken, a lot of people wrote in wondering which episode was the most rewarding or the most challenging. I feel very blessed because I got to direct a lot of significant stories and certainly a lot of important Pam and Jim stories. And I would say the most challenging for different reasons. The fire was very challenging because we spent so much time in the parking lot and it was like 150 degrees. It was the hardest so hard. And Boo's cruise, I love so much. But boy, that boat was not fun. Here's a question. What would you consider the most underappreciated moment in the show? That's a big question. Wow. That's tough.
我尽量不去想凯文。你想问一些观众写进来的问题吗？是的，我们在这里问几个粉丝的问题吧。肯，很多人写信来想知道哪一集是最有价值的或最具挑战性的。我感到非常幸运，因为我导演了许多重要的故事，当然还有很多重要的帕姆和吉姆的故事。我想说，由于不同的原因，最具挑战性。《消防演习》非常有挑战性，因为我们在停车场花了太多时间，而且温度高达150度。太难了，真的太难了。还有《酒水游轮》，我非常喜欢。但是天哪，那艘船可不好玩。这里有个问题。你认为剧中被低估最多的时刻是什么？这是一个很大的问题。哇。这很难。
Wow. Let me think about that. Well, here's a moment or a short scene from the pilot that I always point to as to me one of the best scenes certainly in the pilot is the scene towards the end between John and David when they're leaning on Pam's desk after she has left and they're just leaning and not talking to each other and it goes on forever. And it's just this weird scene of dead air but there's such tension between them. And finally, I can't remember John's line but he starts to engage with David and then David just walks away. It is the it is the oddest little scene. But I love how beautifully like it's very tense and there's not a word and they're not even looking at each other. I just find that that would fall under a great underappreciated
哇。让我想想。嗯，这里有一个试播集中的时刻或短片，我总是把它指出为我认为试播集中最好的场景之一，那就是最后约翰和大卫之间的场景，当时他们在帕姆离开后靠在她的桌子上，他们只是靠着不说话，而且持续了很长时间。这只是一个诡异的死寂场景，但他们之间有着强烈的张力。最后，我记不清约翰的台词了，但他开始与大卫交流，然后大卫直接走开了。这是一个，这是最奇怪的小场景。但我喜欢它如此美妙的方式，比如它非常紧张，而且没有一个字，他们甚至不看着彼此。我只是觉得这会落入一个伟大的、被低估的
moment. I love that moment and it felt so real like in watching it and Jim tries and then Roy's like I'm out. Just walks away. Oh yeah. I love moments like that. We got this question from Justin Sweeney. Justin asked as a director, how do you balance telling actors what to do versus empowering actors to be creative and make their own decisions? You're so good at this, Ken. You're very good. I feel like part of my job as a director is just to simply create an atmosphere where people feel loose and people feel like they can kind of play or you know or fall on their face or make a fool of themselves. I mean I just feel like part of it is is trying to really not be in any way shape or form kind of judgmental in my mind and just sort of like and sort of
时刻。我喜欢那个时刻，它感觉太真实了，就像在观看时一样，吉姆尝试了，然后罗伊说我走了。直接走开。哦，是的。我喜欢这样的时刻。我们收到了来自贾斯汀·斯威尼的这个问题。贾斯汀问，作为一名导演，你如何在告诉演员该做什么与赋予演员创造力并做出自己的决定的权力之间取得平衡？你在这方面太棒了，肯。你非常棒。我觉得我作为导演的工作的一部分，就是简单地营造一种氛围，让人们感到放松，让人们觉得他们可以尽情发挥，你知道的，或者出丑，或者让自己像个傻瓜。我的意思是，我只是觉得其中的一部分是，尽量在心中以任何形式都不做任何评判，然后只是像，然后
you know just kind of love people into their best work and so it's not a specific thing. It's more just kind of and I also feel it's very important to be near the actors, to not be often and I mean obviously this is the case in the office but you know I don't want to be off in another room looking at a video monitor. I want to be near the actors so that when you call a cut the actors look up and you're the first person they see. I've talked to so many actors who work with directors who were sequestered at a video monitor a half a mile away and they say that you know after calling cut they don't hear they get no notes they hear it's radio silence so you're kind of at sea wondering what you know how am I doing so for me so much of it is just being
你知道，只是用爱把人们引向他们最好的作品，所以这不是一件具体的事情。这更像是一种，而且我也觉得靠近演员非常重要，不要经常，我的意思是显然办公室里就是这种情况，但你知道我不想在另一个房间里看视频监视器。我想靠近演员，这样当你喊“卡”时，演员抬起头，你是他们看到的第一个人。我和许多与导演合作过的演员谈过，这些导演被隔离在半英里外的视频监视器旁，他们说在喊“卡”之后，他们听不到任何声音，没有任何笔记，听到的是一片电台寂静，所以你有点像在海里，想知道你知道的，我表现得怎么样，所以对我来说，很大一部分只是
you know near the cast. I'm also kind of awed by actors by the way and I should I'm not an actor at all so I'm just sort of a little bit you know just kind of awed watching. I feel like I have the best seat in the house here. There's one thing I do want to mention about Steve. I know on the Booz Kuru's episode you talked about how you know you were talked about his intensely great you know work ethic and the fact that he was shooting a movie at the same time we were doing the Booz Kuru's and what I remember in there at the beginning of the series is I always tried to get to the set before anyone else to kind of figure out what I was going to do during the day and Steve was already always already there and he was in Michael Scott's office with the door
你知道，靠近演员。顺便说一句，我也对演员感到敬畏，我应该，我根本不是一个演员，所以我只是有点，你知道，只是带着敬畏观看。我觉得我这里有全场最好的座位。关于史蒂夫，我确实有一件事想提一下。我知道在《酒水游轮》那一集里，你谈到了你知道的，你谈到了他极其出色的工作道德，以及我们在拍《酒水游轮》的同时他还在拍一部电影这一事实，我记得在那里，在剧集开始的时候，我总是尽量比任何人都早到达片场，以便弄清楚我一天要做什么，而史蒂夫已经在那儿了，他在迈克尔·斯科特的办公室里，门
closed and he was just thinking about the day's work and he was like he was there before everyone and I thought wow that's that's a pretty cool it's a cool signal for Steve not that this was his intention but what a great signal to send everyone in terms of like being serious about your work. Yeah can you would give me a piece of direction that you gave me more than once and I am convinced it was a Jedi mind trick. Oh I know it I know it. I would do a scene a couple of times and then you would come up to the reception desk and you would say Jenna on this next one what if you you know what never mind go ahead and I would think what if I want what if I want what what was he going to say. Oh my god you're on to me. Is it is it a Jedi mind trick Ken?
关着，他只是在思考一天的工作，他比所有人都早到，我想，哇，这真是个，这对史蒂夫来说是个很酷的信号，并不是说这是他的意愿，但对于向所有人传达关于认真对待工作的信号来说，这是一个多么棒的信号。是的，肯，你曾给我一些导演指导，你给过我不止一次，我确信这是一个绝地心灵控制。哦，我知道，我知道。我会把一个场景拍好几次，然后你会走到前台，你会说，詹娜，在接下来这场戏中，如果你，你知道吗，算了，继续吧，我会想，如果我想，如果我想，他要说什么。天哪，你把我识破了。这，这是一个绝地心灵控制吗，肯？
It it it kind of is yes. What is the purpose of it is it to what what are you doing there? I think maybe the the purpose is to clear your mind. Yeah maybe. I do remember once Steve and I were working on a scene in the episode company picnic and there was just a lot of discussion as there often was you know with the writers between takes and I could tell that Steve actually was a little like felt a little overloaded over noted maybe that's the right way to put it he was over noted and I remember before one take I said okay Steve what I what I want you to do in this next take is like wipe the whole blackboard clean that was all I said that and he goes oh good he was very relieved so well you know Ken I had done an improv pilot
它，它有点像，是的。它的目的是什么，是为了，你在那里做什么？我想也许目的是为了清空你的脑海。是的，也许吧。我确实记得有一次史蒂夫和我正在拍摄《公司野餐》那一集中的一个场面，正如通常那样，在镜头之间，我和编剧们进行了很多讨论，我能看出史蒂夫其实有点像感到有些不堪重负，被给的笔记太多了，也许这是表达它的正确方式，他被给的笔记太多了，我记得在拍摄其中一个镜头之前我说，好吧，史蒂夫，我希望你在下一个镜头里做的是，就像把整块黑板擦干净，我说的就这些，然后他说，哦，太好了，他感到如释重负，所以，你知道，肯，我曾拍过一个没有被播出的即兴试播集
that didn't go and I had done a few commercials but this was my first steady gig as an actor and I remember feeling such comfort when you would say go ahead like just go ahead and it's something the whole cast has always talked about how you would just say go ahead and it was like just you don't scream action yeah you do it for our audience Ken we've talked about it will you do it um uh go ahead there's a lot of different no no there there's a lot of different versions of go ahead by the way there are no that's true in like really emotional scenes like there was always a lot of support in your go ahead for Pam you'd be like go ahead like it's okay like giving you would give me permission go ahead there's a there's a lot of like going back to the Jedi
，我还拍过几个商业广告，但这是我作为演员的第一份稳定工作。我记得当你对我说“继续吧，就直接继续吧”时，我感到无比的安慰，这是整个剧组一直在谈论的事情，你总是会说“继续吧”，就像，你不会大喊“行动”，是的，你会为我们的观众这样做，肯，我们讨论过这件事，你会做吗，嗯，呃，“继续吧”，有许多不同的，不，不，有许多不同版本的“继续吧”，顺便说一句，没有，那是真的，在像非常情绪化的场景中，你的“继续吧”中总是对帕姆有很多支持，你会说，“继续吧”，就像没关系一样，你会给我许可，“继续吧”，有很多像，回到绝地
mind trick there are also a few versions where it's like I'm about to say something and then I just say go ahead where it's like when uh yeah no go ahead yes yes you do that with your hand you'd be like yeah you know what never never mind go ahead and you'd be like what's happening Ken and I got to work together again on Black AF for Netflix and you got to say go ahead and I got to hear it and it'd been so long I almost like in the scene my character wasn't supposed to cry in that moment but I was like oh my god I'm tearing up I'm tearing up because Ken just said go ahead by the way one of the wonderful things about uh that show and our work on that show Black AF is I got to uh see you do improv in a way that I hadn't done the office because that was a lot of
心灵控制，还有一些版本是这样的，我正要说什么，然后我直接说“继续吧”，就像当，呃，不，继续吧，是的，是的，你用手这样做，你会说，是的，你知道吗，不，没关系，继续吧，你会说，发生什么事了，肯和我又有机会在网飞的《Black AF》中合作，你得说“继续吧”，我也听到了，而且已经过去太久了，我几乎就像在那个场景中，我的角色在那一刻不应该哭，但我当时想，天哪，我要泪崩了，我要泪崩了，因为肯刚刚说了“继续吧”。顺便说一句，关于那个节目以及我们在那个节目《Black AF》中的工作，美妙的事情之一就是我得以看到你以一种我在《办公室》中没有见过的方式进行即兴表演，因为那有很多
improvisation and of course as you both know everyone always asks how much the office was improvised and of course you know it mainly was just brilliantly written to sound improvised yes well listen you guys should we get into casino night yeah so casino night received critical praise I found that in a 2011 poll conducted by the fan site office tally fans voted casino night as their favorite all-time office episode that had aired at the time did you have any idea while you were directing it that it would be received like that did you know you were directing this monumental episode within the series I had no idea that I mean you really are not sure how anything is going to come together when you're in the middle of it and and what's so good about
即兴表演，当然正如你们俩都知道的，每个人总是问《办公室》有多少是即兴表演，当然你知道它主要只是剧本写得太棒了，听起来像是即兴的。是的，好吧，听着，伙计们，我们要进入《赌场之夜》吗？是的，所以《赌场之夜》受到了评论界的赞誉。我发现在粉丝网站Office Tally于2011年进行的一项民意调查中，粉丝们投票将《赌场之夜》评为他们有史以来最喜欢的、当时已经播出的《办公室》单集。当你导演它的时候，你有想到它会得到这样的反响吗？你知道你在导演剧中的这一里程碑式的一集吗？我完全不知道，我的意思是，当你置身其中时，你真的不确定任何事情会如何组合在一起，而且
casino night is again I feel like there's so many uh story elements that are just working so well and and I also watching it again I you know I forgot how much of the story is about romance you know there's there's the Dwight Angela the beginning of that romantic story um and obviously Pam and Jim but also you know Michael and Jan and Carol and also seeing I can't remember how much we've seen bob fans before casino night but just seeing the two of them together I don't know I feel like there's there's there's all this you know romance in the air in this story so I really love that it was kind of a date night in a way for a lot of the couples oh yeah Ryan and Kelly as well yeah Ryan and Kelly absolutely all those maraschino cherries
《赌场之夜》最棒的地方在于，我觉得有太多的故事元素运行得非常好，而且我也再次观看它，我，你知道，我忘了有多少故事是关于浪漫的，你知道，有德怀特和安吉拉，那个浪漫故事的开始，当然还有帕姆和吉姆，还有，你知道，迈克尔、简和卡罗尔，还有看到，我不记得我们在《赌场之夜》之前见过多少次鲍勃·万斯，但仅仅看到他们两个在一起，我不知道，我觉得有所有这些，你知道，这个故事中弥漫着浪漫的气息，所以我真的很喜欢对于许多情侣来说，这在某种程度上就像是一个约会之夜，哦，是的，还有瑞安和凯利，是的，瑞安和凯利，绝对的，所有那些红色的马拉希诺樱桃
and I I um I have so many favorite moments from casino night but I have to there's like a couple of tiny ones I I'd love to they're so tiny but I love them so much and one of them and Angela you talked about it after you slapped Dwight and walk away that tiny little moment before you exit frame it's so small it's so beautiful and and it's so great that Randall kept capturing it take after take but what I also love in that shot is that you see both yours and rain's reaction at once it's a very energetic shot because you're watching you're you're kind of keeping an eye on both of you at once it's really great the other tiny little moment is is right before the first Daryl talking head that's when Steve says Dinkin Flicka and we cut to Craig and he gives a tiny
，我，我有太多来自《赌场之夜》的最爱时刻了，但我不得不说，有几个微小的瞬间，我，我很想，它们太微小了，但我太喜欢它们了，其中一个，安吉拉，你在扇了德怀特耳光并走开后谈到了它，在你离开画幅之前的那个微小瞬间，它是那么的小，那么的美丽，兰德尔一次又一次地捕捉到它真是太棒了，但我同样喜欢那个镜头的是，你同时看到了你和雷恩的反应，这是一个非常有精力的镜头，因为你在看着，你，你同时留意着你们两个，真的非常棒。另一个微小的瞬间是，在第一个达里尔单采镜头之前，那是史蒂夫说“丁金·弗利卡”的时候，我们切到克雷格，他在我们切到他的单采镜头之前，对摄像机投去了微小
tiny look to the camera before we cut to his talking head it's barely noticeable but it's so great it's almost as if did the camera just see that like it's such a great little moment and so there's a lot of little beautiful little grace notes like that in the episode you had mentioned that scene with Jan and Jim out by the car and then you positioned that very deliberately can you talk about that yeah I actually I haven't reread the scene description I'm sure I just said that they were standing outside talking but I and they may have actually found this on their own they may have literally just leaned against the car hood side by side and then rehearsed it who knows how that it landed but when I saw it it felt so sexy it felt like wow this feels and plus you know
微小的一瞥，几乎察觉不到，但它是如此之棒，几乎就像是摄像机刚刚看到了吗？就像这样一个精彩的小瞬间，所以在这一集中有很多这样美丽的小细节。你曾提到过简和吉姆在车旁的那场戏，然后你非常刻意地安排了那个位置，你能谈谈吗？是的，其实我没有重读场景描述，我确信我只是说他们站在外面说话，但我和，他们可能自己发现了这一点，他们可能真的只是并肩靠在车引擎盖上，然后排练了它是如何落脚的，谁知道它是怎么演变成那样的，但当我看到它时，觉得它太性感了，感觉就像，哇，这感觉，而且你知道
Malora's smoking a cigarette and Malora is sexy though she's so beautiful you know oh she's no she's she's very sexy and but she's also in that scene she's she's you know such a not good mood which to me actually made me feel even more that this would play as an interesting mislead for the audience oh maybe she's going to you know maybe they're good I don't know something's going to happen with these two and it just felt like that somehow just the two of them just leaning casually against a car hood just felt like it was the right way to go and I also I'd loved it when you did the Casino Night podcast that you you talked about Jan's overnight bag in your car and I loved Jenna what you said you said the camera finds her overnight bag
马拉正在抽烟，而且马拉很性感，虽然她太美了，你知道，哦，不，她，她非常性感，但在那场戏中，她，她，你知道，心情非常不好，这对我来说实际上让我觉得这更像是一个有趣的误导，给观众留下的印象，哦，也许她会，你知道，也许他们很好，我不知道，这两个人之间会发生点什么，只是感觉不知何故，他们两个只是随意地靠在车引擎盖上，感觉这就是正确的方向。我也很喜欢当你们做《赌场之夜》播客时，你谈到了你车里的简的过夜包，我很高兴，詹娜，你所说的，你说摄像机发现了她的过夜包
and I was so delighted when you said that because in fact the camera doesn't find it she holds it up for us to see and I and I remember this I had a big discussion with Malora that night because in the script in in Steve's script it says she tosses the what appears to be an overnight bag over her shoulder into the backseat and and the first take or two that's what she did she just threw it over her shoulder and I thought oh well I have no clue what it is that she just threw back there what is that so I and this is like this tricky acting challenge I said you know what I hate to say it I think you need to kind of hold it up for me to see what it is before you throw it and so we had a discussion about why would she pause and look at it and and
，我听到你这么说时非常高兴，因为事实上摄像机没有发现它，她是把它举起来让我们看到的，我，我记得这个，那天晚上我和马拉进行了深入的讨论，因为在剧本里，在史蒂夫的剧本里写着，她把看起来像是一个过夜包的东西扔过肩膀扔到了后座上，在前一两个镜头里她就是这么做的，她只是把它扔过肩膀，我想，哦，好吧，我完全不知道她刚才扔到后面的那个东西是什么，那是什么？所以我，这是一个棘手的表演挑战，我说，你知道吗，我不愿这么说，我认为你需要把它举起来让我看到它是什么，然后再扔掉它，所以我们讨论了她为什么要停下来看它，而且
we I remember talking to her about you know you this that this bag is like taunting you it's like sort of you know it's like just making fun of you like you know and so she did it so gracefully and and and it feels completely natural even though it's a totally stagey moment I would have had I had no idea I mean we watched it we had no idea yeah I thought it was totally organic I I mean that's brilliant on your part and Malora's part well Malora Malora pulled it off it's so beautiful one of my favorite shots is so not a documentary type shot and I just love it it's the shot of uh Jan and Carol side by side at the bar and Steve's in the background and he notices them and then he slinks out a frame and he's framed sort of it's a very formal very you know
我记得跟她谈过，你知道，这个包就像是在嘲弄你，它就像是，你知道，就像是在取笑你，你知道的，所以她做得非常优雅，而且它感觉完全自然，尽管这是一个完全是摆拍的时刻。我完全不知道，我的意思是，我们看了，我们完全不知道，是的，我以为这完全是有机的，我的意思是，这是你和马拉的杰作。好吧，马拉，马拉成功做到了，太美了。我最喜欢的镜头之一根本不是纪录片式的镜头，我只是非常喜欢它，那是简和卡罗尔并肩站在吧台旁的镜头，史蒂夫在背景里，他注意到了她们，然后他溜出了画幅，他的构图有点，这是一个非常正式的，非常，你知道
he like it's sort of very funny shot but he's framed right in between them he slinks out a frame and then moments later he reappears deep in the background and he's still like sort of monitoring them and it's like such a hilarious shot I don't have any clue what and they're having a dialogue Jan and Carol I have no clue what they're talking about all I'm doing is watching Steve like screwing around in the background they're ordering their drinks and uh let's see um Carol gets very tense small talk yeah that's what they're doing that's what is tense small talk but I just totally every time I see this shot I go oh shit I should listen to that dialogue once in a while I'm just looking at Steve now was it was I wonder if it was in the script that Steve was pacing in the
他像，这是一个非常搞笑的镜头，但他的构图正好在她们中间，他溜出画幅，然后片刻之后他又在深远的背景中重新出现，他仍然像是在监视她们，这真是个滑稽的镜头，我完全不知道，她们在对话，简和卡罗尔，我完全不知道她们在谈论什么，我所做的只是看着史蒂夫在背景里瞎搞，她们在点饮料，呃，让我们看看，呃，卡罗尔变得非常紧张，闲聊，是的，这就是她们在做的，这就是紧张的闲聊，但我每次看到这个镜头都会完全觉得，哦，操，我偶尔真该听听那段对话，我只是在看着史蒂夫。现在我在想，史蒂夫在背景里踱步是剧本里写好的，还是你们在当天拍摄时为了丰富这一场景而想出来的？
background or if that was something you guys found on the day to fill out that scene the scene description says Michael approaches in the background sees the two of them talking and turns on his heels and what Steve did is that he his his back is to them for most of the shot and then he turns and then he doesn't know what to do and then he leaves frame and it's the reappearing in the deep background he's really funny I love that so much he's like sort of stalking them a little he he doesn't know what to do about this this is like way too much action for him another favorite memory of mine is when Creed wins the refrigerator and because I remember uh staging it so that Creed's off camera and he had to load up his sleeve full of poker chips and he had to
场景描述说，迈克尔在背景中走近，看到两人在谈话，转过脚跟。史蒂夫所做的是，在镜头的大部分时间里，他的背对着她们，然后他转过身，然后他不知道该做什么，然后他离开了画幅，在深远背景中重新出现，他真的非常搞笑，我太喜欢了，他有点像在跟踪她们，他不知道该怎么处理这个，这对动作戏来说对他来说实在是太多了。另一个我最喜欢的回忆是，克雷格赢得冰箱的时候，因为我记得，我把场景安排得让克雷格不在镜头前，他必须把他的袖子里塞满筹码，他必须
hold his hand up so or else they'd fall and and as I recall the camera was on Bob and Phyllis Bob Vance and Phyllis and and as soon as Bob announces that Creed's the winner on as the camera whipped over I like gave Creed a hand signal so that he could lower his arm and let the chips all fall out I always I very fond memory of making sure he had his the chips up in his sleeve so Ken we talked a lot about all of the Jim Pam scenes in our Casino Night podcast and John was on and he was able to give his point of view but we had a fan write in Jess Marie asked why did you decide to not let Jenna and John talk to one another before their kiss on Casino Night what was what was in your head there when you were setting up that moment well I felt and I know you and I
把手举起来，否则筹码会掉下来，而且我记得摄像机是对着鲍勃和菲利斯，鲍勃·万斯和菲利斯，一当鲍勃宣布克雷格是赢家时，当摄像机猛烈转过去时，我给了克雷格一个手势，这样他就可以放下胳膊，让筹码全部落下来。我一直有一个非常美好的回忆，就是确保他把筹码放在袖子里。所以，肯，我们在《赌场之夜》播客中谈了很多关于吉姆和帕姆的场景，约翰也来过，他能够表达他的观点，但我们有一位粉丝写信进来，杰丝·玛丽问，为什么你们决定不让詹娜和约翰在《赌场之夜》的吻戏之前彼此交谈？当你安排那一刻时，你心里是怎么想的？嗯，我觉得，而且我知道你和我
talked about this Jenna but we shot the kiss actually the night before we shot the parking lot scene that blew my mind by the way like when when I found that out I was like well I mean I the reason is just a practical one and that was it was the end of the week and we saved our night exterior work for Friday night yeah that's that's all it was so I felt like it was hard because how do you go into the kiss without having experienced that parking lot scene how do you how do you prepare for it how do you and so it seemed to me that maybe having some distance between the two of you might help create I don't know just just this feeling that you're kind of off balance because you hadn't done the scene obviously we'd read the scene we had a table reading
谈过这个，詹娜，我们其实是在拍摄停车场场景的前一天晚上拍那个吻戏的。顺便说一句，这让我大开眼界，当我发现这一点时，我想，好吧，我的意思是，原因其实很简单，那就是那是周末的结束，我们将夜间外景工作留到了周五晚上。是的，事情就是这样。所以我觉得这很难，因为如果没有经历过那个停车场场景，你怎么能进入吻戏？你该如何为它做准备？你怎么能，所以在我看来，你们两个之间保持一定的距离可能会有助于创造，我不知道，只是这种感觉，你有点失去平衡，因为你还没有拍那个场景。显然我们读过剧本，我们进行过剧本围读
but we didn't rehearse the parking lot scene so it was so in a way I was I was I just sort of felt like and I'm sure Greg and I discussed this and he may have had a different idea but I just remember thinking well since we didn't do the scene which was which is really that you know kind of the turning point in their relationship when you know Jim declares that he loves Pam and and and it throws everything you know it upends everything since we hadn't done that if there might be a way just to kind of again create a little tension well it really worked because John told on the podcast that he was like what happened to Jenna where's Jenna he was like is she mad at me what's going on yeah where did she go and I was in my trailer just sort of sitting there feeling very separate
，但我们没有排练停车场场景，所以从某种程度上说，我只是觉得，而且我确信格雷格和我讨论过这一点，他可能有不同的想法，但我只记得当时想，既然我们没有拍那个场景，也就是他们关系中的转折点，当吉姆宣称他爱帕姆时，这把一切都颠覆了，一切都颠覆了，既然我们没有拍那个，也许这只是一种再次稍微制造一点紧张感的方式。嗯，这真的很管用，因为约翰在播客中说，他当时想，詹娜怎么了？詹娜在哪儿？他当时想，她生我气了吗？发生什么事了？是的，她去哪儿了？我当时坐在我的化妆车里，感觉自己和剧组
from the crew and normally we you know normally we didn't spend a lot of time in our trailers we sat on set with the crew while they did their lighting or we were snacking at the snack table and chatting with people so to be sequestered really did create a whole new experience well also I mean once we got into the scene I mean the the lighting was so moody and obviously the you know the crew was hidden and I think and I listened to you know you're you're talking with John about this and he's you know he's right it was weird because I was also trying to like underplay the whole thing and you know and Jenna you and I have talked about this that I was trying to make as little of it as possible even though the call sheet that day said in like all caps
完全隔离了，通常我们，你知道，通常我们不会在化妆车里花太多时间，我们在片场和剧组坐在一起看他们打灯光，或者我们在零食台吃零食，和大家聊天，所以被隔离确实创造了一种全新的体验。嗯，还有，我的意思是，一旦我们进入场景，灯光是那么有情绪，显然剧组是藏起来的，我想，我听了你和约翰谈论这个，他是对的，这很奇怪，因为我也试图淡化整件事，你知道，詹娜，你和我谈过这个，我尽量不把它当回事，尽管那天的通告单上用大写字母写着
Jim kisses Pam and but I I I do feel like it was important that you guys be off balance yeah it worked it worked I mean beautifully so I also remember the discussion about whether to have a second camera to capture in effect your side of the kiss Jenna and I and and and I do remember as you you guys mentioned that Randall was totally opposed to it and he's you know absolutely right there should definitely only be one camera and what I also remember though was I had a I was wrestling with whether or not to ask John to come further into the room when he came towards you because if he did it became in effect it became downstage a little more it would force you to open up the camera and the shot would then be like the two of you in complete profile facing
“吉姆吻了帕姆”，但我确实觉得你们俩失去平衡是很重要的。是的，管用了，管用了，非常完美。我也记得关于是否要用第二个摄像机来捕捉詹娜你的吻的视角的讨论，我确实记得正如你们提到的，兰德尔完全反对这样做，他是绝对正确的，绝对应该只有一个摄像机。不过我也记得，我当时在纠结，当约翰走向你时，是否要要求他再往前走一点进入房间，因为如果他这样做了，实际上它会更靠近前台一点，这会迫使你们敞开摄像机，然后镜头就会像你们两个完全是侧面对着
each other and you know it's like how do you how do you shoot it how do you stage it how do you photograph a kiss and that's you know very classic Hollywood you know Ingrid Bergman and Humphrey Bogart facing each other on the tarmac you know it's like so but I decided at the last moment that that wasn't our show that would that would be that that would be too Hollywood-y for our show and so we shot it and I remember first of all I was probably you know crying watching the scene but I remember thinking that the other reason the camera angle was so good so appropriate was that Jim knows what he's about to do Jim has such a strong intention he's coming there to kiss Pam but that Pam is unaware of it and is surprised and we're surprised so the camera angle really
彼此，你知道，这就像，你怎么拍？你怎么安排？你怎么拍摄一个吻？那是非常经典的好莱坞风格，英格丽·褒曼和亨弗莱·波加特在停机坪上面对面，你知道，所以我在最后一刻决定那不是我们的节目，那对于我们的节目来说太好莱坞化了，所以我们拍了它，我记得首先我可能在看着场景时哭了，但我记得我想另一个摄像机角度如此之好、如此合适的原因是，吉姆知道他要做什么，吉姆有着如此强烈的意图，他来这里是为了吻帕姆，但帕姆对此一无所知，感到很惊讶，而我们也感到惊讶，所以摄像机角度真的
kind of puts us in Pam's shoes and and sort of we are Pam you know we're surprised by it as well so it felt like another angle would have really hurt the way we are involved in that moment but then we had to restage it oh my god I know that was so weird we had to wait all summer to find out Pam's reaction and then the only way to get it was to restage that whole moment was that so hard as a director to recreate a moment so that it seemed like it was just playing out I mean I kind of don't even know how we did it a lot of people wrote in asking wait did you film the beginning of gay witch hunt on the casino night you just waited and you saved the footage and it was like no we completely recreated it and let it play out I remember being surprised when I saw the gay
有点让我们站在帕姆的角度，我们就是帕姆，我们对此也感到惊讶，所以感觉另一个角度会真正损害我们对那一刻的投入。但随后我们不得不重新排练。天哪，我知道，太奇怪了。我们不得不等待整个夏天来寻找帕姆的反应，然后获得它的唯一方法就是重新排练整个时刻。作为一个导演，重新创造一个时刻让它看起来像是在自然发生，这有那么难吗？我的意思是，我甚至不知道我们是怎么做到的。许多人写信问，等等，你们是在拍《赌场之夜》时顺便拍了《同性恋大搜捕》的开头吗？你们只是等着，保存了素材？就像，不是的，我们完全重新排练并让它上演了。我记得当我看到《同性恋大搜捕》剧本时我很吃惊
witch hunt script because we I mean we hadn't gotten I mean this script I don't think it was written when we shot casino night so and I do remember going oh my gosh we got to do that again because I thought it was such an emotional it was so you know it was so kind of draining for everyone not in a bad way but it was just emotional and but it I remember being a lot you know a lot breezier of a job to recreate it you know because the way you do is not nearly as heavy no no Ken thank you so much for coming on the podcast today thank you I had such a blast this is it's so great to see both of you and I just so happy I'm part of this show well you have to come back okay I mean listen we've got a few years here we're gonna be giving you up
，因为我们，我的意思是，我们还没有拿到，我的意思是，当我们拍《赌场之夜》时，这个剧本好像还没写好，所以我也记得当时想，哦天哪，我们得再做一次，因为我认为这是一个如此情绪化的场景，对每个人来说都太耗费心力了，不是以不好的方式，它只是情绪化的，但我记得重新排练它要轻松得多，你知道，因为你做的方式没有那么沉重。不，不，肯，非常感谢你今天来到播客，谢谢你，我度过了一段非常快乐的时光，能看到你们两个太棒了，我太高兴我能参与这个节目了。嗯，你得回来，好吗？我的意思是，听着，我们在这里还有几年，我们要给你安排
with some questions okay well I will put in a request for when you get to company picnic Jenna I think we need to have a discussion about your volleyball skills yes we will have you back for company picnic for sure you guys I want to tell you that Ken is without a doubt one of the very best directors I've ever worked with I feel so fortunate to have worked with you Ken and he has a book coming out it is called but what I really want to do is direct lessons from a life behind the camera it comes out October 6th but it is available for pre-order now on Amazon I got an advanced copy so I've already read it oh please guys if you're an aspiring director if you want to know more about just the experience of what it's really like to direct please pick up Ken's book
一些问题，好吧。嗯，我会提出一个请求，当你拍到《公司野餐》时，詹娜，我认为我们需要讨论一下你的排球技术。是的，我们一定会请你回来的，为了《公司野餐》。伙计们，我想告诉你们，肯毫无疑问是我合作过的最好的导演之一。能和你合作我感到非常幸运，肯。他有一本书要出版，书名叫《但其实我想做的是导演：镜头背后的生活教训》。它将于10月6日出版，但现在已经在亚马逊上开启预购了。我拿到了一本预发版，所以我已经读过了。哦，拜访各位，如果你是一个有志于成为导演的人，如果你想了解更多关于导演真实体验的知识，请买一本肯的书吧。
but also I mean there's so much about your philosophy in this book that could really just be applied to life in general Ken it's it's a beautiful book thank you thank you it was such a pleasure to write and I'm so excited to get it out there I can't wait to get mine and then I'm gonna text you about it so get ready for your phone to blow up I have found a quote about your book from Larry Wilmore he's one of our writers and I'm gonna read it to everybody okay do it do it it says action is what most directors bark out to begin a scene but Ken Kuapis starts by gently intoning the words go ahead that simple suggestion assures everyone they're in smart capable humble hands and that's how you'll feel reading his book and so if you're anxious to discover how a top director
但同时，我的意思是，这本书里有太多关于你人生哲学的核心，真的可以应用到一般的生活中，肯，这是一本美丽的书。谢谢，谢谢，写这本书是一种乐趣，我很高兴能把它带给大众。我等不及要拿到我的书了，然后我会给你发短信，所以准备好让你的手机被打爆吧。我找到了拉里·威尔莫尔对你书的评价，他是我们的编剧之一，我要把它读给大家听，好吗？读吧，读吧。上面写着：“行动”是大多数导演在开始一个场景时大喊的词，但肯·夸皮斯开始时会温柔地低吟“继续吧”这几个字。那个简单的建议向每个人保证，他们是在聪明、能干、谦逊的手中，而这就是你读他的书时的感受。所以，如果你渴望发现一位顶级导演如何
always brings humor honesty and humanity to his work all I can tell you is go ahead perfect Larry Wilmore that is so beautiful Ken and so true so true thank you thank you and all I can say is I'm gonna keep listening to this podcast I so enjoy weekly getting to listen to both of you so oh thank you well I'd love to come back good well we would love to have you back and guys we're gonna put Ken's book up on our website officeladies.com you can find it there but like we said it's also on Amazon but if you're looking for a quick link you can head over to our website and we will link to it there and in the show notes thank you Ken we love you love you I love both of you and I hope to see you soon
总是将幽默、诚实和人性带入他的工作，我能告诉你的一切就是：继续吧。太完美了，拉里·威尔莫尔，太美妙了，肯，真是太真实了。谢谢，谢谢，我能说的一切就是，我会继续收听这个播客，我非常享受每周收听你们俩的节目，哦，谢谢。嗯，我很乐意回来。太好了，嗯，我们非常欢迎你回来，伙计们，我们会把肯的书放在我们的网站officeladies.com上，你可以在那里找到它，但就像我们说的，它也在亚马逊上，如果你在找一个快捷链接，你可以前往我们的网站，我们会在那里以及节目简介中提供链接。谢谢你，肯，我们爱你，爱你。我也爱你们两个，希望很快能见到你们。
I mean who's better than Ken Kuapis nobody nobody he's the best he's the best I love him so much Ken I have saved several of your Christmas cards is that weird love you okay um so we have just a few more things to discuss Jenna okay Latimania wrote in and said something I'm curious about Pam often fussed with her engagement ring most noticeably when Jim walks away after his big confession was that a script direction or was that Jenna's own added touch Latimania you are always so thoughtful with your questions they always stand out to me thank you for asking you know Latimania is the artist who does all of the beautiful drawings of scenes from the office we've talked about her yes podcast before okay so that was not in the script
我的意思是，谁比肯·夸皮斯更好？没有人，没有人。他是最好的，他是最好的，我太爱他了。肯，我保留了你几张圣诞贺卡，这奇怪吗？爱你。好吧，嗯，我们还有几件事要讨论，詹娜。好吧，Latimania写信说了一件我很好奇的事。帕姆经常摆弄她的订婚戒指，最明显的是在吉姆大肆表白后走开的时候。那是剧本指导，还是詹娜自己添加的点缀？Latimania，你的问题总是那么深思熟虑。它们总是让我印象深刻。谢谢你的提问。你知道，Latimania就是那位画了所有办公室场景美丽画作的艺术家，我们之前在播客中谈过她。好吧，所以那不在剧本里。
that is something I do in my life I'm a bit of a fidgeter but I did make a conscious decision for the character of Pam to fuss with her engagement ring to Roy while in that scene with Jim because you know that ring that she feels on her finger is why she's not saying what she really wants to say oh that's good lady that's so good so that was that was an acting choice I think that's so good well listen I loved that question I appreciated that you noticed my little acting choice there that means a lot to me actually I like that you know I tried to put those details into the character and into my performance and it always feels really good when people notice so thanks yeah also lady we got a ton of mail about your big brother kid sister bit with John I know
那是我生活中会做的事，我有点喜欢坐立不安，但我为帕姆这个角色做了一个有意识的决定，在与吉姆在一起的那个场景中，摆弄她对罗伊的订婚戒指，因为你知道，她在手指上感觉到的那个戒指，就是她没有说出她真正想说的话的原因。哦，那太好了，Latimania，太棒了。所以那是一个表演选择，我觉得太棒了。嗯，听着，我很喜欢那个问题，我很感激你注意到了我的小表演选择，这对我来说意义重大。我喜欢你知道我试图将这些细节融入角色和我的表演中，当人们注意到时总是感觉非常好，所以谢谢。是的，还有，Latimania，我们收到了大量的信件，关于你和约翰的大哥哥小妹妹的梗。我知道。
okay so and remember how you and John were talking on the podcast and you were trying to remember what the actual name of the boy doll was called and we couldn't remember yeah well a lot of people wrote in Karen Tom Kay Willy won all said the boy doll's name is my buddy and Angela not only that the original commercial is still on YouTube oh I know I went and watched it guys I went and watched it can we play a little bit of that there it is big buddy kid sister Angela my buddy my buddy not big you said big buddy oh my gosh my buddy we will never get we literally just listen to it and it's not landing on me but here's I can only hear big brother kid sister because that's what you and John did for so long on set but Angela here is what creeped me out when I
好吧，还记得你和约翰在播客中谈论，你们试图记起那个男孩娃娃的真实名字叫什么，而我们记不起来了。是的，嗯，很多人写信来，凯伦、汤姆、凯、威利·旺，都说那个男孩娃娃的名字叫“我的好朋友”（My Buddy）。安吉拉，不仅如此，原版广告还在YouTube上。哦，我知道，我去看了，伙计们，我去看了。我们可以放一小段那个吗？就是那个。大哥哥小妹妹，安吉拉。我的好朋友，我的好朋友，不是大哥哥。你说是大哥哥？哦，天哪，“我的好朋友”。我们永远不会，我们字面意思刚刚听了它，但它没有在我脑海里留下印象。但我能听到的只有大哥哥小妹妹，因为那是你和约翰在片场做了那么久的梗。但安吉拉，这里让我感到毛骨悚然的是，当我
watched that commercial and I saw that doll my god it looks like you oh come on lady braid your hair and you are kid sister it is well John is who started it he said to me he called me kid sister and then clearly classic Kinsey I got it wrong and I went big brother instead of my buddy well he nailed it on kid sister because the resemblance is eerie well I guess I'm just gonna have to go get one don't get one it will scare people in your home if they come upon it it'll be like you putting a chucky doll in your house you can't do it I'm gonna get one and I'm gonna put it by my mailbox I thought you were gonna say you're gonna put it in my window or something and I'd be like ah what I think no I have to no don't you how do you how do you prank
看了那个广告，看到了那个娃娃，天哪，它看起来像你。哦，拜托，Latimania，把头发编起来，你就是小妹妹。这真是……嗯，约翰才是发起人。他对我说，他叫我小妹妹，然后显然是典型的金西风格，我搞砸了，我说了大哥哥而不是“我的好朋友”。嗯，他在小妹妹这一点上说得很对，因为相似度太诡异了。好吧，我想我只能去买一个了。不要买一个，它会吓到你家里的访客的，如果他们碰巧看到它。这就像你在家里放了一个查奇娃娃一样，你不能这么做。我要买一个，我要把它放在我的邮箱旁边。我以为你要说你要把它放在我的窗户上或者别的什么地方，然后我会想，啊，什么？我想，不，我必须，不，你怎么能，你怎么能在
someone in a pandemic that's how you get a creepy doll and set it outside their window a creepy doll that looks just like you yeah all right guys we also got some mail that is not specific to casino night okay why do some characters on the show have character names like Pam Jim Roy Dwight and some have their real names Oscar Creed Angela Phyllis we get this question I would say the most it's in the mail every single week yeah every single week so I feel like we have maybe answered this before but we want to take it again we do we answered it in one of our candy bag episodes but we're going to answer it here because we really feel like people want to know well listen you know we had asked Greg about this and he said obviously some characters are based on characters
大流行期间对某人恶作剧？这就是你弄一个诡异娃娃并把它放在他们窗外的方式，一个长得跟你一模一样的诡异娃娃。是的。好吧，伙计们，我们还收到了一些与《赌场之夜》无关的信件。好吧，为什么剧中的一些角色有像帕姆、吉姆、罗伊、德怀特这样的角色名，而有些角色用他们自己的真名？奥斯卡、克雷格、安吉拉、菲利斯。我们经常收到这个问题。我想说，这封信件每星期都会出现。是的，每星期都出现。所以我觉得我们可能以前回答过这个问题，但我们想再回答一次。是的，我们在一期糖果袋节目中回答过，但我们要在这里再次回答，因为我们真的觉得大家很想知道。嗯，听着，你知道，我们曾就此问过格雷格，他说显然有些角色是基于英国原版《办公室》中的角色，对吧？
from the original British office right Jim and Pam and Dwight and then there were these new characters and it was myself and Oscar they we weren't in the original and they just used our names and and just kind of it stuck I think what's interesting Angela did Greg ask your permission to use your name or did he just name you Angela no no one said anything the only conversation I ever remember having is he asked me if I had any pitches for my last name oh and and I did pitch Martin but this was several episodes in I was already Angela and then we were talking about well what what would your last name be and I I wrote down a list of them and one of them was Martin and that cleared is that significant to you in some way is Martin family name or something
吉姆、帕姆和德怀特，然后是这些新角色，我和奥斯卡，我们不在原版中，他们只是用了我们的真名，然后就一直沿用了下来。我觉得有趣的是，安吉拉，格雷格征求过你使用你名字的同意吗？还是他直接给你取名叫安吉拉？不，没有人说什么。我唯一记得的对话是，他问我对我的姓氏有什么想法。哦，而且我确实提出了“马丁”，但这已经是好几集之后了，我已经是安吉拉了，然后我们当时在讨论，你的姓氏会是什么？我写下了一个名单，其中一个是“马丁”。那很清楚，这对你有什么意义吗？马丁是一个家族姓氏还是别的什么？
no I just was trying to think I thought it was interesting that Kevin was Kevin Malone and Oscar was Oscar Martinez and then I'd be Angela Martin would be the three M's and then we for years had a running joke that our spin-off would be the accountants go have their own firm called M M and M I love it I love it well there you have it guys that's that's why some people have their real names and some people have character names nothing like their name yeah I think the writers just were like we'll use their names it's really not probably that interesting of a story but there you go guys thank you so much for sending in your questions this was so much fun I I loved this revisited episode Angela honestly one of our favorite things that that we do is get to read
不，我只是在想，我觉得有趣的是，凯文是凯文·马龙，奥斯卡是奥斯卡·马丁内斯，然后我会是安吉拉·马丁，这就是三个M，然后我们多年来一直有个长期的玩笑，我们的衍生剧会是会计师们去开办自己的公司，叫做M、M和M。我喜欢，我喜欢。好吧，这就是原因，伙计们，这就是为什么有些人用真名，有些人用角色名。跟他们的名字一点关系也没有。是的，我觉得编剧们当时只是想，我们就用他们的名字吧，这可能不是一个那么有趣的故事，但事实就是这样，伙计们。非常感谢你们发送问题，这太有趣了。我，我很喜欢这集重温，安吉拉，说实话，我们做的事情中最喜欢的之一就是阅读
comments and interact with you guys and I just love that I love the office Jenna and I obviously loved the show so we love getting to interact with fans that also loved it and have questions and comments and things that you caught that we missed I love all of it I also really like the idea of being able to deep dive with some of like the original visionaries for the show like we have to get Dave Rogers our editor we've got to get Carrie Bennett who designed our wardrobe season one in the beginning and and like Randall Einhorn our cinematographer kentopedia kentopedia we have to get kentopedia okay so yes I don't know what we're gonna call these but from time to time we're gonna give you what do we want to call it Angela a deep dive a revisited we'll figure it out you
评论并与你们互动，我就是喜欢这个。我喜欢《办公室》，詹娜和我显然都很喜欢这部剧，所以我们喜欢与同样喜欢它、有疑问和评论、以及捕捉到我们错过了的东西的粉丝互动，我喜欢这一切。我也非常喜欢能够与该剧的一些最初愿景者进行深入探讨的想法，比如我们必须请来我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯，我们必须请来第一季和最初设计我们服装的凯莉·贝内特，以及像我们的摄影师兰德尔·因霍恩，肯百科（Kentopedia），肯百科，我们必须请来肯百科。所以，是的，我不知道我们要怎么称呼这些，但我们会不定期地给你们，我们想叫它什么，安吉拉？一次深入探讨，一次重温，我们会弄明白的，你们
you guys actually tell us if we do an episode like this again should we call it the deep dive or the revisited I like the deep dive well I mean you got a deep you got a dive you put them together get a deep dive no no no that's my son did that my son that's my son Angela and you're like no no that is horrible okay oh my gosh hilarious okay okay so guys keep sending in your questions we have folders over on office ladies comm to submit questions for specific episodes you can also send us an email at office ladies at your wolf comm yes we love engaging with you in our social media you can follow us over at office ladies pod on instagram and thank you so much to kin quapas and thank you guys so much for listening in yeah we'll be back next week with the merger
其实可以告诉我们，如果我们再做一期这样的节目，我们应该叫它“深入探讨”还是“重温”？我喜欢“深入探讨”。好吧，我的意思是，你得深入，你得潜水，你把它们组合在一起，就成了“深入探讨”。不，不，那是我的儿子做的，那是我的儿子，安吉拉，而你会说，不，不，那太糟糕了。好吧，天哪，太搞笑了。好吧，好吧，伙计们，继续发送你们的问题吧。我们在officeladies.com上有文件夹可以提交特定剧集的问题，你也可以给我们发电子邮件，邮箱是officeladies@earwolf.com。是的，我们喜欢在我们的社交媒体上与你们互动，你们可以在Instagram上关注我们@officeladiespod。非常感谢肯·夸皮斯，也非常感谢你们大家的收听。是的，我们下周将带着《合并》回归。
thank you for listening to office ladies office ladies is produced by ear wolf jenna fischer and angela kenzie our producer is cody fischer our sound engineer is sam keefer and our theme song is rubber tree by creed gratin for ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes candy bag go to stitcher premium dot com for a free one month trial of stitcher premium use code office There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的主题曲是格雷格·格拉坦的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听该节目的无广告版本以及我们的专属节目《Candy Bag》，请访问stitcherpremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。